a day after leaving taipei u.s house
speaker nancy pelosi met the speaker of
south korea's national assembly in seoul
she appeared unbothered by the
controversy sparked by her visit to
taiwan
and spoke warmly of the military and
economic relationship between south
korea and the united states
a relationship that began
from urgency
and security many years ago has become
the warmest of friendships but pelosi
left troubled waters in her wake
chinese military helicopters fly over
the taiwan strait of pingtan in southern
china at the start of live fire
exercises that effectively surround the
island
chinese state tv broadcast video of
missiles fired from the mainland into
target areas close to territorial waters
taiwan claims as its own with its
fighter jets in the air in combined
exercises designed to show china is in
complete control
the purpose is to show that the people's
liberation army is capable of
controlling the taiwan island a great
deterrent to taiwan's independent
secessionist forces nonetheless china's
foreign ministry blamed escalating
tensions firmly on the united states
if these countries really cared about
peace and stability in the taiwan strait
they should have persuaded the united
states not to engage in dangerous
reckless and irresponsible provocations
against china before pelosi's visit to
taiwan they pretended to be deaf and
silent but now they jumped out to
criticize china's just actions exposing
their hypocrisy and ugliness
china's live fire exercises are expected
to continue for the next few days
possibly even until early next week
by that time nancy pelosi will be back
in the united states but the impact of
her visit to taiwan will be felt here
for some time to come tony chang al
jazeera
taiwan's defense ministry says it's used
flares to drive away drones flying over
one of its islands close to mainland
china the incident happened in the
straits between taiwan and china there
are a number of taiwanese islands closer
to the mainland than taiwan let's take a
look kinman is the set of islands
overflown by the drones in the 1950s it
was shelled by china the u.s considered
using nuclear weapons to protect it xiyu
is part of the kinman islands that's the
chinese mainland in the back of the
photo there
china's warned ships to avoid the area
for 72 hours because of ports like xi'an
men half the world's annual shipping
goes through this area
earlier i spoke to wen t song who is a
specialist in china taiwan relations
with the australian national
university's taiwan studies program he
believes beijing's military drills are
an attempt to de-legitimize
taipei's claim of autonomy
that part of the world near taiwan
straight accounts for more or less half
the world's maritime commerce so in that
sense it's certainly a very critical
ceiling of communication uh choke point
in a way
which is also why it's raising a lot of
interest as was concerned for other
countries in the region
at this point though i think
the fact that china designates its areas
for military drill in this particular
way
may potentially be a sign of
reassurance however ironic it may sound
because
for me the way i read it is that china
is doing the ministry drill in those six
areas three of which overlap with part
of taiwan's territorial waters
precisely because china is more about
diplomatic messaging more so than
preparing for next round of major
military offenses
and the way to think about it is that
they are trying to counter the
diplomatic message of nancy pelosi's
trip to taiwan the logic is pelosi being
such a senior official building taiwan
somehow
helped legitimizes and strengthens
thailand claim
to be a sovereign state actor
and so china now is trying to counter
that effect by showing no taiwan is not
a sovereign state actor i'm gonna show
you by saying
i'm gonna do military drills in taiwan's
territorial waters i'm gonna ban
maritime shipping
during or throughout thailand's
territorial waters as well just to show
that taiwan does not have true autonomy
to govern those places and therefore
it's going to delete the mice and weaken
taiwan's claim to its own
autonomy and self-governance